from the director of Tammy the boss so
the boss is directed by the director of
Tammy who is Melissa McCarthy's husband
Ben Falcone or Falcone different
on-screen batman laura has made me
forever question how you pronounce that
last name however gonna clear your mind
right now
this movie's not as bad as Tammy so in
the boss Melissa McCarthy plays Michelle
Darnell she's a super successful super
rich lady who did some insider trading
and so she goes away to jail for some
amount of months and then she gets out
but the government's frozen her ass has
repossessed her halas took all her
possessions she really has nothing so
she stays with her old assistant
Claire's crashes on her couch and then
she goes with Claire's daughter to this
ultimately Girl Scout meeting and she's
like oh my god it's how we're gonna get
back in the game it's how I'm gonna be a
businesswoman I'm gonna build an empire
like a brownie Empire and so that's what
this movie is it's a crude comedy about
this lady building a brownie Empire with
Kristen Bell and I'm going to say I
laughed pretty hard and quite a few
scenes in this movie first of all
Melissa McCarthy is great at comedy
she's just we all know it yeah she plays
the same thing and it's getting kind of
annoying they know she's gonna play this
movie just really crass really crude
really blunt [ __ ] and it's classic
it's not like this groundbreaking thing
either you know Melissa McCarthy is this
very sanguine disturbing element that
comes into Clara's life and Claire is
really you know she doesn't go outside
the box you know she's really boring so
this lady's gonna teach her and then
Claire's gonna teach her what families
lie somewhere in the middle is where a
real normal human being should be and
they're gonna help each other out seen
it a billion times before I know but
this is Melissa McCarthy's movie and she
does a good job in it because unlike
Tammy she's not completely [ __ ]
obnoxious in fact a lot of people she's
a dick to in this movie they really
deserve to have an [ __ ] be an [ __ ]
to them so it's really validating to see
just love to see it it's in that
vindictive kind of way and the hits keep
comin in this movie she always has a
snarky ass remark to say about a lot of
[ __ ] and I'm pretty sure it's probably
that Melissa McCarthy ad libbing but as
we've seen in outtakes before on
blu-rays and DVDs or end credits scenes
Melissa McCarthy's really good at
ad-libbing
Julie surprise in this movie that I
actually liked her be is she still kind
of plays Melissa McCarthy's characters
all of them who are kind of one person
Kristen Bell was good but in the end
Kristen Bell just could have been any
girl whatsoever that just just any girl
hey can you play kind of a lonely single
mom yeah after your higher job audition
for anybody for that role the movie is
ridiculous there's a total street brawl
that happens where you're like that
would never actually happen but the
street brawl is actually pretty
impressive just I'm just saying it's an
impressive street brawl but you do think
to yourself like is this where they go
in the cartoon like at first she was
like the super snarky dick and you liked
seeing it but now are we crossing the
threshold to cartoon not quite yet not
until Peter Dinklage he's the element
that brings this movie to cartoon level
and that really compromises the
experience like a last act of this movie
Peter Dinklage officially makes it a
cartoon and it was just a weak-ass last
act I got a break into this place Peter
Dinklage is sword fighting it's really
[ __ ] strange I'm like where'd this
come from where is the vibe coming from
where did we get brace for this [ __ ]
suppose the movie was bracing you for it
all along and saying that he's obsessed
with samurais duh but when it actually
goes down you're like oh you mean you
were serious kind of like when I got an
earring I yeah I had an earring at one
time watch my old old old videos and
told my I told everybody tell my family
I would get an earring when I graduate
I'm gonna get an earring when I graduate
they're like that's funny and then I got
and they're like oh [ __ ] you mean you
were serious about that this guy now it
feels Peter Dingle is like samurai-sama
and you're like uh-huh and then he like
actually starts sword fighting and being
completely ridiculous and you were like
oh you mean like we were going there oh
I should have taken you a little more
seriously not gonna lie this was jarring
guys in the end the boss is like this
Melissa McCarthy plays exactly what you
think Melissa McCarthy is going to play
however she does it in a way that's
actually more fun to watch than a lot of
her recent movies except spy spy was
better its need to see the super crude
crass loudmouth hurricane come into
someone's live and actually make it
better and actually have a business
model in mind because I've always
thought that about brownie Scouts I'm
like what's your end game what do you
get out of this so she kind of
challenges that dynamic she's like now
my brownie troops you make 5% you get
commissioned pretty good way to go about
it and I thought that was cool to see
but not all the jokes land and when they
miss they miss with a vengeance there
are a couple leading up to the last
accurate
like no you were doing so good until now
but that last act just left me shaking
my head and I was like give love why did
we even know that's stupid just
concentrate on the family stuff you
don't have to make it some big thing by
the end you just make it keep it in the
pocket man keep it personal but in the
end I will say I laughed in this movie
and that's what a comedy is supposed to
make you do I will say I had a good time
with this movie I will say the boss is
certainly a good time no alcohol
required or I see your favorite and
least favorite melissa mccarthy movies
just quite a contrast now so you have
some pics to pick from whatever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more